today I have brought you three different
games from the years 35 54 in 85 I'm
sure we'll manage to go over two of them
properly and and the third one I'm not
sure but like I did last time in the
last lecture if we don't have time to
see the whole game properly I will just
mention the names give you encourage you
to look for the game in the databases or
online you can see this game online all
those games online and yeah I think it's
a worthy worthy lecture now this is
really funny because the first game I'm
showing you I've heard the name of it
and I haven't seen it in many years I
think the last time I saw it I was not
good enough to appreciate it and it's
called the pearl of zon port somewhere
is a city in Holland a town in Holland
and it was where the match between
maxover and alexander alekhine ano Qian
was played in 35 and it was called the
pearl of it because it was supposed to
have been a really impressive game and
it is impressive in the sense that what
you will see in it unfortunately somehow
when you check it with some computer
like let's say stockfish six my favorite
you will see that this is more like the
garbage of zone 4
I mean this is the game turns out to be
really bad there are so many mistakes
for both sides and it like in the
commentary that's given in the chess
based megabase it's like almost like a
mirror mirror opposite every time they
give a question mark
it's a critics clam every time it's a
next time it's a question like
everything is upside down I don't
understand it so very discouraging for
me nonetheless the game is still worth
looking over because even if a game is
imperfect something we're all very
familiar with even me you can enjoy it
but let let's try to respect the game
because in with hindsight and instruct
v6 everybody's a genius in 1935 when you
have to play for the World Championship
met with so much at stake and all the
nerves and tensions in the time control
and the ticking clock it's much harder
so maxover is white alexandra Jochen is
black
d-46 i always love seeing a lurking
games because he was many things about
opening expert he definitely wasn't and
he always tried to like let's just get
rid of this opening somehow play a
middle game and then things got
interesting so he plays a six God knows
why
see for f5 okay so he wants to play the
dusted a g3 Bishop before check okay I
move like this definitely needs some
explaining the point is that part of
whites ideal setup would be to develop
the knight Bishop Castle then play b3
and again depending on how black is
going to set his pieces either put a
bishop on b2 in the case that you will
play Bishop e7 d6 etc or if you play d5
and Bishop d6 then I will want to play
Bishop a3 to trade bishops so as to
accentuate my control of the e5 square
so this move kind of forces something
that white doesn't want to do because
like also the knight wants to go to d2
and then when the knight from F 3 jumps
to e5 he wants to be able to do this
also he wants to be able to play a four
so now everything is kind of if you play
Knight c3 you pin it it's like a names
of Indian where I managed to get f5 in
that's obviously applause or you have to
play Bishop d2 like in the game then I
just retreat with my bishop and your
Bishop on d2 is a bit funny so again a
little nuance not exactly an amazing
achievement
so Bishop g2 Knight f6 Knight c3 okay
the bishop is on d2 took away this place
from the night and now tonight just
comes here
castles very nice Knight f3 and now very
impatiently IURC in place the move
Knight e4 okay already the commentator
said that better was d5 but the computer
says that 94 is not worse but definitely
the move Knight e4 is Calabar a little
early just feels like dude what about
the rest of your pieces but didn't we
learn don't move the same piece twice I
know that you are a grandmaster and
world champion but still of course after
d5 defect would make a lot of sense
because this setup for white is not the
most dangerous against it obviously like
we said the bishop should be elsewhere
the knight should be elsewhere
not okay he plays 94
and white can afford to cancel normally
the bishop is not on detail and then 90
X 9 breaking up the pawn structure could
be really annoying but with the bishop
on d2 we don't have to worry about that
and white can afford to cancel and black
plays the move b6 I should say this is
game 26 in their match to two games ago
black played the move Bishop f6 and now
he tries to improve with b6 but this is
not an improvement by the way but not
because of the next movie he played in
the game Queen c2 when you put this in
stock fish 6 another churn for a little
bit he is a big proponent of Knight
takes here he really really likes Knight
X here pawn takes 95 looks a little
counterintuitive because you think the
knight is going to be changed to where
but listen I'm about to take pawns and
I'm about to attack rooks and this is
big if you play d5 my knight on e5 is
super justified so believe me I'm not
gonna there's no way I can analyze this
game at length or we a will not see any
of the others B will never finish this
one we only have one just under one hour
for the lecture but again trust me when
I promise you take stakes 95 would have
been very testing so Queen c2 Bishop to
be 795 I think that here d5 got a lot of
praise again nowadays there are this
this idea is very well known to play d5
and after Knight takes Bishop takes it
becomes a real mess notice that you can
just win a pawn because of that pin on
the long diagonal so d5 very sensible
alright
95 Knight takes c3
yeah they mentioned it on d6 of course I
can just take on e4 and black is not
ending happy they're right about that so
takes Bishop takes c3 this move this
this analysis I think I added by myself
because I asked myself why on earth
don't they mention anything about this
move is just losing the answer is no
it's just a lot of compensation for
black check winning the pawn saving the
knight then taking here hitting the
Queen
when the Queen moves knight c6 and of
course if you take on c6 if you take on
a a queen takes a a well that's really
nice
so Knight takes c6 and then maybe Bishop
AAIB okay compensation anyways he didn't
bother to test that Bishop takes c3 of
course he's just unnecessary to try it I
just thought it was working but it's not
so Bishop takes G to King takes G to so
just like that two sets of minor pieces
have been traded and I think that for
now white is doing quite alright he is
better developed he has a little more
space his King is comfy no less than
blacks everything is cool
Queen c8 this move for the life of me I
cannot understand maybe he wanted to go
to b7 but I think it's really obvious
that this that white is going to do
something in the center way before the
Queen reaches b7 so where exactly is he
going I think the computer was very much
in favor of the move Queen eight trying
to go this way I think that makes more
sense
so queen c8 and now notice the move d5
the annotators give it a big exclamation
mark the computer says nope that's not
the best move the computer says efore is
very strong
efore is definitely definitely
definitely the move in this position and
again no time to do deep analysis
believe me if you want when you go home
check it out
remember my notes you can see it on
YouTube stop pause it and analyze if or
is really a praise of a move so d5 d6 93
a five all right so my this sequence
some of you might say wait a minute why
did white allow the closing after
position yes he did but notice that
there are two beautiful squares here
that will always hunt black to some
degree and for now he's also a little
behind in development and now some
strange moves have been played first of
all white plays this move that to me is
kind of a lazy move I don't think
there's any amazing urgency to play it
why didn't he play f4 immediately I do
not know I
people just made sense to play a four in
this position therefore in this position
but he didn't he played here and black
played c6 yeah also they mentioned it at
some point
f4 is interesting but all right let's
see what c6 no problem
now night at Queen b3 hey legitimate
move and now blacks plays returns the
favor that white just gave him and plays
King h8 again in my opinion and in the
computers opinion not a good move at all
just unnecessary much more logical was
to close the position this way and after
here here here and white would maneuver
Knight very similar to the game by the
way and it's okay
so after Queen b3 King h8 just really
not necessary
so f4 there is no way to defend the pawn
on e5 which is attacked already three
times so E for forced night before the
idea is very simple I want to play deep
x e6 when you Knight takes it I want to
help with my Knight to d5 if that
happens and I end up with the knight on
d5 with this weak pawn and this
structure that is going to be party time
for me so c5 hitting and now the night
goes to c2 of course the knight wants to
land on e3 I don't want to put a pawn on
e3 I want to put the knight on e3 with
her but this pawn here
I just weakened the square and my knight
doesn't have a home if I put my knife
here the pawn is just as blockaded and
my knight is looking at all kinds of
things so night here normal 93 and now
Bishop f6 again I move that rose color
on uncommented but I think it's it's
very very suspicious and this is where
the computer was really funny because
initially you think yourself that
everything is fine the computer says
this is OK but when you let it churn for
a little bit then the continuation in
the game kind of changes the assessment
so what should we have played that's all
really difficult to suggest but
definitely not Bishop f6 maybe
Queeny eight again would make some sense
i think you know even King g8 would have
been better to play g6 it's a moment
would have been more logical but just
not Bishop of six yes you will see
there's a promise for the what happened
in the game so again it looks like
everything is okay but now over a brush
it really appreciates the fact that he
can make a change in the position a very
dramatic change sacrifice a piece for
three pawns and the ensuing ending is
going to be in his favor
of course not before a yoke and misses
some counter chances so very strong very
very good again I am positive that
someone at the level of the world
champion at the time saw it
unfortunately for him he just under
evaluated it missed something we will
never know he's not with us to ask but
when you see the continue in the game
you start understanding that this is if
only from excuse me a practical point of
view really not a good decision to enter
something like this because the burden
of proof free will be on you he tries to
play aggressively he tries to prove it
wrong but the game makes it very
difficult so on we go Knight X are fine
the only way to justify this is you have
to be consistent Bishop takes here
Knight takes T six now you have to be
able to attack the knight because
otherwise I just take on c3 and thank
you for the two pawns if you go to c7
I'm gonna go Knight b5 that's not fun so
it forces the next move which is Queen
b8 and now Knight takes e4 Bishop f6
okay already the computer is starting to
be a little annoying with his nitpicking
he says Bishop d4 not exactly sure why I
tried to figure it out but they didn't
analyze this game for 10 hours so I
don't really know perhaps he wants to
lower III but I don't think this really
makes a big difference
so Bishop here for sure this move is
excellent and the reason is being shown
by the arrows I have a very nice bone
phalanx in the center cdef and I want to
just
move it like like a fireball forward
so the night hands can move and this is
here g5 a very aggressive move but the
computer is ok with it
you think that this is yes I'm willing
to consider it but I'm not sure that the
queen is necessarily better first of all
the knight can be easily protected let's
say Queen c7 but I'm not a hundred
percent that the Queen on b5 is really
safe because I can always kick it and
you'll get to you'll have to go
backwards also you'll notice that the
Queen has a vested interest to stay on
the third-ranked because of chances to
swing yeah fair enough a decent question
so 92 g5 trying to create some mess of
course he is really praying in every
language that he knows that maybe
everything's g5 will happen but needless
to say that there's no chance in the
world I'm not giving you this square not
even for 10 times more than that so on
we go advancing so it takes second
prayer of the day maybe the rock will
take no obviously not
yeah I mean some people think hey maybe
I'll take with the rook I don't want to
mess up my King's side if I move with
the Jeep on the King looks a little Airy
and drafty but no of course like this so
f4 Bishop to d4 not sure that was really
necessary but again sitting and waiting
is not a bad strategy as you will see in
a second so here he five very well I
have to tell you that but I saw this
game my first inclination is listen
before it's going to be more expensive
let me take the stupid pawn now I want
to I don't care take a piece have a nice
day let me spring out of it because when
I see this wedge right here I'm starting
to sweat all over I mean it's black I
don't care to have an extra piece three
of those pawns are for my piece
materially I'm not even up and those
pawns well you can
just see what happened interested again
how far those pawns made it the points
made made it far so let me take now
maybe I'll be down the pawn I'll be
suffering a little bit but with this
super unsafe King maybe I have some
chances the computer agrees but before I
look at the computer just the intuition
is to take those pawns to convince say
this and take those pawns now all right
he doesn't take the pawns he plays Queen
e8 so there goes that idea the pawns are
not going to be capture above anymore
and nonetheless what to do now because
if you play Knight f6 and I'm gonna go
Knight f3 your proud Bishop on the long
diagonal is no law no more you just took
away his retreat if you play Knight f6
Bishop Bishop Knight f3 so while your
king starts with his little sticks and
he plays rook to g8 very good definitely
good especially in view of the idea that
it takes d7 Queen e2 and all of a sudden
White is going from happy to not so
happy so he played
Knight f3 now you see how the
commentator says dubious well I think
the computer says strong but ok very odd
they can be really likes this man so
queen g6 ok and now yeah interesting
would have been to play yeah now that
again all those comments are becoming
really really weird
so Knight g5 95 counter play this I
think the computer says something like
you know 10 above like really equal or
something like that really something
ridiculous so but again this is this
gonna take days to analyze in the game
he went rook to g1 just investing more
material so takes takes and he played
Queen f6 ok notice that it says Queen f6
mistake
we are not wife is winning the computer
says Queen a5 Queen f6 the same equal
the same value and equal so I don't know
what I tell you this game but may God be
rhythm okay but Queen I find takes
takes takes and now the annotators say
this but the computer says Queen takes
f4 equal y equal I don't know how to ask
me this is too messy this is really too
messy I'm showing you this for enjoyment
not for not for deep study this is
really deep so we are here and Queen f6
Knight g5 okay and now rook g7 I think
was okay but I'm not a hundred person I
don't remember all the analysis okay but
I think that was alright
he takes d7 rook takes d7 Queen III and
rookie seven is good so far 96 rook your
fate okay there are not million
possibilities this other than the note
is like a million things if we do that
we'll be here all night
Queen e5 Queen takes takes
now it says rook to e8 rook takes e6 is
the best the computer completely
disagrees the computer says Ruka five is
fine and now here is where it gets
really crazy now the you could see the
brook g5 getting explained and then the
gun the line goes rook takes Knight
takes blah blah blah but after Luke g5
rook f2 equal the computer sells the car
I trust the computer in that position
believe me so in any event the computer
gives this dubious the computer says
best nerve so I mean the annotate the
other Taylor says dubious then yeah so I
mean this is really funny but it's
really really tough that's a tough
position to analyze much easier when you
have starfish next to you you become a
hero so anybody that's mad about my
teasing sorry but it's factual that
people analyze it in a very funny way so
in this position one thing everybody
agrees with that this was a blunder this
was a bad note-taking now would not be
ridiculous would be very very much
granted chances the other move was King
g8 I think okay he also was was
reasonable if I remember correctly but
one thing for sure the consensus is that
this was the losing
this is by far the losing move because
now the night is starting to make crazy
things 98
well I think everybody knows they're
taking on ephod not so good because at
the end 9 F 7 is going to be a fork so
right if takes takes takes and then
check taking so ruk F 2 e 6 yep now it's
very difficult now somehow he just
doesn't manage to our coordinate and the
pawns are way too strong so root D 2
trying to stop d6 and I hear attacking
the rock the road goes here if you move
the rock away from the file I'm just
gonna go 7 and I make a new queen
anyways he's 7 B 5 again trying to
generate counter play but you notice
that now it's just completely black is
completely paralyzed one rook has to be
in touch with this pawn the other one
has to stop the at the d6 d7 avalanche
but when you have two rooks staying
behind one pawns and I have more pieces
that is going to hurt
so b5 and he plays Knight to d8 King g7
the idea was of course that if you take
I can play D 6 and 9 F 7 and again
everything just works fine or 9 f 796
also possible everything is just working
so he tried this night here again the
night in system coming to d6 check here
here ok and of course you could have
just taken immediately in the computer
says +5 or something
he tried Chacma that was good enough and
in this position black resigned so okay
maybe I was a little harsh by saying
that it wasn't the Pearl and said some
really mean word but again they're just
all the mistakes very very much my data
they don't the game itself is not that
bad it's very excited again when you
have to play it again under all the
pressure that I mentioned with no
computers then it's definitely
challenging so nice win for max over all
right our next game
is going to be is described as vasily
smyslov immortal game
okay a little bombastic but definitely
one of his best games ever this we can
disagree and this is with his match
against Mikhail Botvinnik in 1954 again
the much of the analysis now is based on
Kasparov's annotations unlike before so
d4 Knight of six c4 g6 g3 Bishop g7 not
a surprise by any means both sides are
playing stuff that they expected and
everybody expected Bishop g2 castles
Knight c3 g6 Knight f3 97 ok a normal g3
free I'm jet a variation of the King's
Indian white is developing controlling
the center about the castle black needs
to have his normal hit at the center
which will be e5 and there it is efore
c6 everything normal
and now Kasparov mentioned some lines he
mentioned h3 Queen b6 very similar to
the game so he played Bishop e3 to take
this thing out of Queen b6 however now a
new move is possible for black and he
does it
Knight to g4 Bishop g5 so this is all
well known the knight is attacking the
bishop but the bishop immediately
creates some discombobulation here and
normal here is I think f6 or Bishop f6
also possible but he plays Queen b6 okay
a very interesting game is now in front
of us pawn h3 I don't have to tell you
that if the knight goes back then the
black strategy is just bankrupt
completely bankrupt because what was the
pressure on the center if the knight now
is going retreating so he takes very
good this line lost a lot of popularity
for white by the way in recent years so
now you don't want to play hg beat D
takes c3 and of course black is nearly
winning with the bishop on the long
diagonal and the white pawn structure is
just ruined so 9a for
at first it may look like whoa maybe
black blundered because this night that
was attacked is moving attacking the
Queen with a tempo and now the bit
denied on g4 is a gonner however black
is gonna regain his piece the following
way
Queen a6 takes d5 so the knight is
trapped anyways
again this position is more or less
equal I suppose you know give or take
again and yeah 93 play 94 I think that
the computer suggested something else
maybe Bishop f4 or something like that
should be okay so in an even not so
important because this is also pretty
equal here and here until now we had
just a normal opening more or less this
position is relatively well known but
now Botvinnik plays a move that in my
opinion is a little bit out of character
because normally he is the scientist is
the methodical player plays very
calculative lee and here he plays a
little gamble the move itself is not a
horrible blunder but it's definitely not
the best move he plays Knight takes c6
okay b3 defending the pawn on c4 would
have been a sedated response I suppose
but he decides he calculated decides to
go for it and watch what happened this
is where Smith's lab really shows
amazing understanding so of course he
takes if you don't take then you are
really in trouble takes e5 Queen takes
c4 Bishop takes 8 that was the idea
sacrificing an exchange white wants to
win in exchange Knight takes e5 alright
so this is the deal that he made he won
the rook on a8 in return black has lots
of activity and again the pot on g4
looks like a gonner these black is gonna
get that so materially speaking he is
gonna be okay and now the question is
what's gonna be more significant the
rooks that definitely don't have
shortage of open files or the pieces
also black's pawn structure is kind of
funny
and watch what happened in this game so
now Queen d6 the computer says also
Queen d6 is okay and you can take on g4
I think after Queen d6 the computer even
says Bishop e6 just not rushing to take
the pawn on g4 maybe tonight we'll take
it and again black is doing all right
but he played rook c1 and queen before
Queen b5 again the annotations here I'm
not 100% I think that the computer is
just not as agreeable as agreeable but
alright Queen B for a3 and takes all
right Queen takes a four you can see
that white managed to trade the b-pawn
for the black a pawn and again until now
you think yourself okay what is so
amazing about this game everything is
under control but again the evaluation
is probably the most accurate thing the
most important thing you'll notice that
here but when it wanted is thinking that
he's gonna be really okay and Smith's
love just proves him completely wrong
Bishop e7 and now comes the move that
makes the game exciting because if you
would have played in this position
Bishop takes b7 Queen takes b7 and then
let's say rook c3 just saying listen
dude I'm gonna give you the exchange
leave me alone I'm gonna have bishops
ending and you pawn structure I'm gonna
get the a porn probably I can get the D
pawn if I play Bishop e7 and things are
gonna be alright just the game would not
be exciting whatsoever probably it will
go towards a draw but Botvinnik becomes
greedy with rook v1 and rugby 1 in my
opinion is not a good move not just in
my opinion in Kasparov's opinion in the
computers opinion and
now what to do it looks really gloomy at
first because we are forking skewering I
should say the Queen and Bishop on b7
the rook is protected
you know let's start with the fact that
white is up in exchange to begin with so
what to do
well Smith's love just starts playing
pacman with the white pieces first of
all he plays nine a free check for King
everything King h1 the only move that
doesn't run into captures with Chuck now
he took the bishop
rook takes b2 you won the queen Knight
takes g5 King moves ready to play f4 I
guess so Knight f3 back you go
and back you go you don't want to
because you go right into the discovery
of 92 at some point Bishop takes beat
you so we have this unique position
where black has three minor pieces for
the Queen and this is always a question
what is better the pieces or the Queen
in this case I think that the pieces are
better even though the Queen is quite
active and will take it upon on a 7 and
the pawn on a will start moving a little
bit but still I think that this game
really demonstrate why minor pieces are
better than the Queen and that is really
a nice display right now you look at the
position and you think it's hard to
assess right it's not fair if you say Oh
black is better because there's complete
disharmony among the pieces sure the
bishop on a8 is defending the knight on
f3 and I don't know 3 is sitting pretty
but other than that the rook is on FA
the bishop is on b2 we don't see
anything concentrated and white indeed
takes the pawn on a7 like I promised but
now from this position if you add [ __ ]
in your mind
watch how black it's almost like only
black was playing that's the impression
that you get and this is very impressive
so Bishop a4 a4 well black was
threatening among other things rook e8
and upon on a3 just dies and then
there's really no counter play or any
hope so a4 King g7 again just in case
the rook is gonna move and it
move away from f8 to a more activity we
don't want to have a surprise where you
get like check and then the bishop falls
you know some accidents like that this
is again a Karpov Ian typically Karpov
Ian move the keys away from danger
so rook to d1 Bishop e5 the bishop goes
back to civilization Queen c7 rook to c8
so you noticing that all the black
pieces are starting to have some really
real say in the position a five whites
only eight
what else does here an attack on the
king he won't have sacrificing on d6 is
just clearly not enough you know we're
just gonna have a material advantage for
black so he tries a five rook c2 almost
as if saying you know you're a pawn is
really not none of my concern
so King g2 a very sad necessity of
course if I'm gonna get to take the
pollen f2 you're gonna have mates from
every direction I'm gonna be threatening
mate on h2 and Knight g5 star is just
going to be horrendous
so King goes back into discovery and the
good news is that the knight has nothing
to take you just can't really kill with
this night so then I just adjust himself
here King here
Bishop f3 it's almost like a symphony
all the black pieces from they were like
in the Diaspora and somehow they're all
coming to one promised land and become
very very annoying so rook b1 okay and
in this position he played knight c6 and
I think that here but we Nick resign
because well he is not moving anything
and I'm about to go Bishop d4 and things
are just depressing so they say if this
Bishop d4 Queen takes d6 check here
check here
rook h2 and if the quote the movie that
was mentioned before taken good luck yes
really good luck Luke h1 is not working
good yeah so resignation was inevitable
again I think that's telling it is
saying this is an immortal game by Smith
is a bit extreme because he didn't get
three pieces for the Queen he didn't
just second Queen for two pieces or
something that would really blow our
mind but again the way this the way he
managed to get his minors from nowhere
right into a big attack against the king
completely hopeless White's a poor never
had any chances all right out we go from
this game and on to the next one and
here we have a very impressive game from
a very impressive match in in Russia in
1985 and between the two perennial
opponents Anatoly Karpov who was a real
world champion for ten years until he
met Kasparov and in this match of course
he lost the title if you remember if I
remember correctly I think he lost game
24 but this is game 16 also if I
remember correctly but I don't see it
written here I'm pretty certain that
this is game 16 and probably has four of
his best game of the match again let's
look at what happened with black he
played a really beautiful game so in
that match they had this variation many
times arguing about that specific
Sicilian line Knight b5 b6 c4 so we have
some sort of a Marazzi bind kind of
structure with the pawns of course there
are many many ways to play here you can
play Knight c3 Queen c7 is just the
normal time alarm but this was the
discussion here here here here and
Kasparov played the very very
rambunctious d5 if you don't play that
then the game goes into normal lines
character this is going to be just in
Karpov x' typically to carpoza liking
bishop here bishop here castles knights
e2 just maneuvering completely holding
off d5 and b5 so Kasparov says okay you
played all this c4 and Knight c3 even
willing to put your night somewhere in
Honolulu there just so to stop d5 and
guess what there it is for you yes
no no I don't but don't ask me for the
reputation I was trying to think about
it today when I was preparing the
lecture but I think it's gonna take me
like three hours to detail of course I
could have been more efficient by asking
one of my favorite Asian friends are
probably gonna give me the answer like
this but I can say that I have what's
worse block here gets an advantage I
don't even know how so I mean this is
just but just great activity so of
course the to prove the gambit wrong you
must accept it and he does and now he
just wants to give the pawn back knowing
that with a bishop on f3 and the long
diagonal it's gonna be pretty good
so Kasparov says yeah you know what I'm
not interested in the pond just yet
Bishop c5 castles castles Bishop f3 I
think that here what was limb of the
computer gave but I think it was also
played at some point I think that one of
the discussion was something with Bishop
III and then still Kasparov got a lot of
pressure because even though it's a very
impressive Center it's not really going
anywhere the dark squares are all here
and I'm not saying it's good for an
advantage but it's hard to do anything
with white but okay Bishop here Oh
probably another thing that I want to
ask because after this he played ok this
is still ok so Bishop f3 Bishop a5 now
you played this move rook e8 and Queen
d2 but it would have been interesting
maybe to play the move these six it's a
moment like maybe now and open up the
bishop even if the pond gets lost
eventually anyway he was about to lose
it right here
so just to play d6 and try to keep him
busy with a beep on so it seemed that
the computer was in favor of just
pitching that pond right here so Bishop
g5 rook e8 Queen d2 b5 and this is not a
good move for sure very very are
typically I think I mean Carper must
have had a really really bad data
because Roque d1 is not good even here
d6 seems like a very decent idea give
that pawn away already open up the
bishop get chances maybe at some point
threaten 95 or capture and f6 a 95 and
maybe you can create some
balance where you will be alright in the
game he plays this innocent move just
protecting an extra pawn and all of a
sudden Kasparov played his knife here
not a very difficult move you see now
white is facing a plethora of headaches
the knight is a real pain he's really
cutting the board in half like this is
his border all of a sudden here's a
little wall that prevents him from
advancing I don't want to say anything
about the move before that just
precisely will win a piece so yeah thumb
something is gone already wrong this
position is already definitely better
for black pawn or no pawn black has all
the play so yeah when you have to start
making moves like this you know that
something went Blooey so he went here
eight six chasing the bishop away the
bishop maintains the pin before
attacking the knight not a for Bishop d6
so again we can see the complete harmony
among the black pieces knight on d3 is
like a trueborn in the throat really
annoying protected by the good bishop on
f5 we have a bishop on d6 that serves
many purposes controls this square and
this beautiful diagonal and yeah White
has a pin that's maybe the most joyous
thing to write home about but still
black is in complete control bishop g3
understandable that diagonal is becoming
very very risky very very dangerous so I
think trying to trade pieces especially
when you up upon make some sense rook c8
pawn to b3 notice in this position the
prettiest picture here is notice the
problem of the boat of both nights the
one on a four and the one on b1 let's
see how long before they moved have they
moved until the end I don't even think
they'd they moved ever so pawn to g5
okay maybe not the best move according
to the computer the computer was really
in favor of the move Bishop e5 just
improving further controlling more and
again very very delicate position noted
that this rook is moving this bishop
reason
moving things are very tough you know
very very tough position so this was
still not the end of the world but
Bishop e5 was even stronger now takes
takes g3 97 again even the white is up
upon the pole is not Queenie and it
feels like only black has a plan he is
maneuvering in the meantime the white
knights are just incomplete just out
Bishop g2 in anticipation of the correct
95
so then Queen f6 is controlling
everything the whole centre the whole
board the to open files to just imagine
how much space points he is up if we
start counting just endless so a three
again with a little prayer maybe he's
gonna take but of course that will never
happen
that pawn on b4 is alone responsible is
responsible for the crippling of this
Knight
so a5 takes takes didn't really change
the picture at least he got rid of his
we keep a pawn that's okay
Queen a two again when you are when you
are down to playing moves like this you
know the things are not happening but
again it's hard to be creative you can
suggest all kinds of things but again I
promise you the computer is already
completely in Black's favor and Kasparov
would have also so here bishop g6
interesting the computer was toying with
the move that I didn't think about
because I was trying to think what will
black play here tried to guess the moves
I didn't guess Bishop g6 but I think
this is just Kasparov saying listen I
can and therefore I do my bishop is
going to a protected square my Queen
gains some more points of space and more
exit points but the computer really
wanted to play the move Knight II won
and well it's obviously why this move is
good because I just want to take this
bishop if I think this Bishop mine is
really gonna be annoying so the problem
is that if you even dream about taking
and I trade then rook c2 and the Queen
is well made it yeah not good
everything is just not good so I think
horeb I don't know if he saw it and he
thought that you know it's fun to
torture him so why do dissing finish the
game so I don't know but this is also
not exactly a terrible mood so d6 that's
very obvious desperation g4 step by step
methodically almost like a hyena after
his prey
he's just chasing him closing the gap
and you can just feel it coming Queen d2
King g7 no rush f3 okay I'm nervous move
but what else to do block is about to
play Queen d4 anyways and you're not
moving anything I mean you are really
not moving any pieces things are really
not happening every piece is just the
bishop is really restricted the rook on
f1 isn't moving the rook on d1 can't
move the Knights can't move it's like
almost like a mini Zeus man so he tries
to do this so bye-bye pawn okay having
said a let's say B check knight f6 the
knight is now coming into the game
really toward the force by car Sparrow
really rook F 494 the finishing touch
okay resignation here would have been
very very gentlemanly and maybe the
proper thing to do in the game he played
Queen takes Knight F to check takes
Bishop takes and rook teacher so already
we can see that material is speaking
things are not happening he is trying to
get a third piece he's gonna get that
third piece and this is definitely a
position that kind of compares with the
one I showed you before
it might be three pieces against the
Queen but well before the pieces were a
little bit in the diaspora and
immediately gathered to cause damage
here we have room for some doofus on the
side and the bishop that just shoots in
the air all the way to an empty
not good so queen III roof takes here
and again Kasparov can play a lot of
winning moves here but he makes always
the most this was his evil tendency
especially when he was at his peak
always the strongest move that the
hardest to to really answer now rook
takes Queen rook takes d1 Bishop f1 rook
takes III and the position crumble is
going to be two rooks against three
pieces where the three minor pieces just
don't know object just you lose them
everything is going you can lose a
knight or a bishop you can lose
everything
so Knight B to Queen f2 beautiful just
saying okay you want the rook on c1 it's
yours rook e1 is coming with mate very
aesthetic even the finish is just
aesthetic to think who is playing
against this is not the game in a cylon
against some random he's playing anatoly
karpov the saving world champion and
watch what he does it's just incredible
Knight d2 and of course now mate is
coming takes takes
check resigns game over after Luke f1 or
Bishop f1 or not f1 just takes takes
takes mate it's not everyday did you see
Anatoly Karpov falls like laundry in a
game like this just completely gets
trashed very very impressive really
really impressive one of Crespo knows
best game I think he said that this is
one of his favorite games for sure the
best game of the match and again after a
game like this you really you just have
to feel some feelings of grandeur
because it's just like almost like a
conductor in an orchestra I just made
everything play like a symphony
beautiful alright guys that concludes my
showing for today I hope you enjoyed the
lecture see you next time